so last week was quite a sad week for me
and my family because on Wednesday the
24th of February Linda will donor who
looked after me as a child and my
brother and sisters died at the age of
nearly 95 Linda was Austrian and she
came to England just after the Second
World War
she's one of those people who suffered a
lot during the Second World War
her fiance died she had been imprisoned
by the Nazis for part of the wall
because she had given tea to some
prisoners and she came to England and
looked after me from when I was a tiny
baby she wasn't a chemist but what was
exciting to me was that her father had
been director of a steel works in the
town of rotten man where she lived and
he'd had a lab and when I was a young
teenager she brought some equipment
which you can see some pieces here to
England for me to use or to try and use
and it was really mysterious and
exciting took me years to work out what
it was these do here are called gas
pipettes and they're used for analyzing
gas you have to fill them with mercury I
never had enough mercury to fill them
but as you if you fill them with mercury
then you can use the rotary to pump gas
in and out and she also gave me this
strange piece of equipment here and even
though it's nearly 50 years since she
gave it to me I have absolutely no idea
what it's for
perhaps somebody watching this will have
an idea it has a thermometer which goes
up to about 30 degrees centigrade it's a
glass container which presumably you put
a liquid in and Linda let me have a
little lab in the basement and to do
chemistry in the kitchen where she
washed her clothes and she was even
quite tolerant when they put potassium
permanganate on some of my sister's
clothes
they went brown but I tried not to do
that too often so Linda was very fond of
candles so I thought it would be nice to
light a candle in her memory and just to
say to all of you that it's very
important whoever you are to remember
the people that helped you as a child
and made you what you are today